figurez vous qu'il ya beaucoup de télé
crochet où il ya des castings les
castings sont souvent filmées sont
souvent nous mauvais et donc on les met
de côté moi j'ai retrouvé des castings
pour un télé crochet qui n'ont jamais
été diffusés on peut les appeler les
losers exclusivité les vitres garde est
produit par aulas je suis malade a dit
qu'il n'est jamais très loin qu il pas
très souvent ramoné africa dieu ne st
pas une victime
elle a les yeux revolver elle a le
regard qui tue pendant aux meules et moi
au bout de la terre on te protège
complètement malade hoya
[Musique]
alors the losers qui fera la pire
version maintenant c'est vous qui allez
voter on va revoir à regarder candidats
un candidat 2 3 4 5 6 et vous allez
choisir à votre avis les deux qui mérite
d'aller en finale vous en choisissez un
chacun vous avez un petit panneau non
c'est le plus mauvais 1 bat vous
choisissez le meilleur du pire en pire
du pire qui prévaut lockyer des pierres
mais vous ne saisissez pas le même tous
les deux à l'est joyce
à qui pensez vous tu as aimé
allez joyce alors allez-y marque donnée
nous annonce il vous plait il chante une
chanson message quand eddie malades
ouais mais dans quel état ils sont
choisis qui en deux on prenait bien aux
voeux mais mon petit poucet abonnés
concernés donné mille casques alors
venez vite
le principe est simple est-ce qu'il
chante je demande à la régie la chanson
qu'ils ont chanté durant le magnéto ils
s'inventent la chanson qu'ils veulent on
est en train de me donner les règles au
fur et à mesure c'est un show qui ça
profite à qui c'est ma tension relevé le
pas ce que j'ai entendu parler je vous
jure
bah oui ces bras cassés production ce
soir vous allez donc chanté la chanson
vous avez chanté la qui était quoi les
yeux revolver mais vous allez le
chantait avec une autre chanson d'un
casque ans avait été nommé le meilleur
c'est parti les yeux revolver
elle a les yeux revolver à la le regard
qui tue à la tire et la première m'a
touché c'est foutu nallet l'usure est la
première à bah oui bien sûr
c'était mieux on sait quel moment donné
vous regarderez sur le rythme on a
failli partir sur l'heure de la danse
des canards
elle a les yeux verts avoue gilles
qu'est ce que vous allez nous chanter je
suis malade
alors si ça c'est pas de nouveauté et on
y va c'est parti je suis malade ont
complètement malade
comme dans ma mère portait le soir et
qu'elle me laisser seul avec mon
désespoir et monsieur carrière nabil a
déjà un ace que l'émission vous
intéresse une émission sur la couture
attention c'est vraiment la nouvelle
tendance c'est à dire que je pense qu'on
va se prendre de la couture en veux tu
en voilà y compris sur des huit espaces
interagir n'était pas que je fasse pas
partie de la tendance mais moi ça ne
m'intéresse pas du tout cristina cordula
corps de logis exactement car d'où là il
ya julien lepers uno nous vous lançons
un défi ici de chanter le lundi au
soleil maintenant en direct depuis
baltard
le lundi au soleil ce centre possède
qu'une chose qu'on n'aura jamais chaque
fois c'est pareil c'est quand on met des
relégables quand on travaille que celle
est beau